No, I followed you like when you were at your peak, so...
Oh, ow!
Ow, okay.
You know what?
You can just take the attitude.
Ow.
I guess I'm washed up, Jack.
I mean, how many years ago was...
I guess I'm washed.
Washed up.
I mean, it was one click.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
How about this?
I'll follow you back.
Yeah?
All of you shut up, my friend Fuzzy Stucks.
All right, all right.
Okay, follow me first.
No, no, no, no, no.
This is bad.
No.
No, no, no.
Follow me first.
How would I know?
I already did my one click.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
Because that was besides the point, okay?
You're not fucking nervous.
You're not fucking nervous, bro.
See that?
Like, that's besides the point, okay?
Dude, this is like a more skill-based game.
All right, all right.
How about you follow me first and I'll give you your shout-out?
It's just that easy.
I'm scared.
Because that's the thing.
It's the issue, right?
It's the issue.
Yeah?
Whether Fuzzy gets the shout-out or not, it doesn't benefit me at all.
Yeah, but you clearly want to do this for your chatter.
You clearly, because it's day two and you're still on about this Fuzzy guy.
You could have moved on after day one.
Yeah, but I don't think he can move on.
That's the issue.
Yeah, so if you really like your chatter, if you really appreciate them, follow me on Twitter right now.
Fuzzy, Fuzzy, are you in my chat still?
How much?
Or Fuzzy, ditch that guy and come to my chat.
I'll appreciate you.
Fuzzy, Fuzzy, you're, like, you're Fuzzy.
Fuzzy sucks.
Now's the time to like him.
Fuzzy, if you come to my chat, I'll give you a shout-out and I won't even end.
Only on my stream.
Yeah, no, he just said, I'm in Doki's chat right now.
Oh, shit, yeah, and your guy was like, I'm the Sonic chatter too.
Oh, man, your fat's coming to me now.
I don't need that follow.
I got Fuzzy already.
Take him, take him.
You don't need him?
All right.
That's why you got ninthplace.com a breaker, Fuzzy.
Other viewers in Sonic chat, I would appreciate you.
I would follow somebody to give you that shout-out.
But apparently, Sonic chat is the best way to get that shout-out.
Sonic doesn't care.
Sonic doesn't care at all.
It's literally one click!
That's right!
The offer's gonna go!
Alright, if you don't do that follow, you'll never get that shoutout or Sonic or Fuzzy back.
Fuzzy, you're gonna have to beg me for this.
You're gonna have to beg me for this because there's no incentive.
The fact that you can't even do one click...
It's a lie!
Fuzzy, I didn't mean it.
I'm sorry.
Fuzzy, you don't have to beg in my chat.
Listen, Doki, I can tell we're both stubborn people, so how about this?
I don't follow you.
Yeah?
But...
But?
You shout out Fuzzy anyway.
Alright, goodbye.
Fuzzy's my chatter now.
You know what?
Take him!
You know what, Fuzzy?
You're gonna have him!
You know what?
I'm out of here!
He's the viewers in Sonic's chat!
I won't do the run that he did!
Listen, if there's a chance in this next minigame where I can save your life and, you know, we can both, you know, survive and thrive together, okay?
I'm clicking the eject button and I'm gonna watch you... I'm gonna watch you perish!
Okay?
I'm gonna watch you perish!
I'm gonna be... I'm gonna be...
All I'm saying is that I have the support of my fans.
I don't know about you.
I'm gonna be clasping my hands together, okay?
I'm gonna be clasping my hands together.
I guess you fall to your demise.
Feels like you're projecting Sonic.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay?
Is this a bad thing?
Oh shit!
Fuzzy, thanks for the sub, Fuzzy!
Oh my god!
Fuzzy, you're not a real one.
You're not the real one.
You won't do stuff for your homies.
I'm not real at all.
I'm the real one!
Good job, Fuzzy!
Hey guys, so like...
Yeah, like...
that came out of nowhere.
I was literally eating...
And then Sonic just came over, and was like, hey...
And I was like, hey...
while I was trying to eat.
I was really trying to speedrun my fucking lunch.
During the waiting room.
And...
Okay...
I have my half-finished fucking meal in front of me.
Um, the content came to me.
Yeah, SonicFox jumpscare.
I was like, oh shit, okay.
I guess it's content time.
Hello everybody, welcome to day two.
You know like, okay, you know what's funny?
After day one, I was like, oh my gosh, why did I...
I was like, oh my god.
I could have been eliminated and just chilled.
And like, I told my friends, and my friends were like, bro, you could have like...
Why did you do this to yourself?
And I was like, but I just wanted to win.
I just wanted to survive.
And then, yeah, my friends were like, you're so stupid.
So, I guess I'll be here for days.
Day two!
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna get eliminated on day two though.
Oh my gosh, but my exposure!
My free exposure, chat!
For the 1k?
Bro, 1k I need to survive for like, two more days, guys.
Like, this lobby is like 90% Minecrafters.
There is no way any of us are gonna... any of the normies out here that don't play Minecraft...
are gonna survive to day three and four.
Oh my god.
Anyway, so yeah.
Welcome to day two of the Minecraft Twitch Rivals.
The haunted house.
I think the next, this game, this game that we're gonna be doing...
is like, we're supposed to like, dodge the monsters or something.
And like, run from them and avoid them.
So, that's basically it.
I don't know if the...
Let me know the cinematics.
By the way, there's no emote mode today.
Yeah, apparently the monsters are gonna be chasing us.
Like, we have to cross some zones.
And then we have to...
We have to cross some zones and...
Get to the monsters and...
Like, avoid the monsters and stuff to the safe zone.
What else do I want to say?
Oh yeah, there's no emote mode this time.
Because there's nothing to ghost at the moment.
So, there's no emote mode.
So, you guys can like, backseat me for...
You know, if there was...
If there was no emote mode in the very first game, I would have known about the...
The tech.
You guys would have yelled at me about this...
The jump tech, guys.
You guys would have done...
Yelled at me about this.
Anyway...
Is Fuzzy still in my chat, Fuzzy?
Oh wait, I hear Goomy.
Goomy!
Hi!
Donkey, I was looking for you earlier and I found you but you were AFK.
Wait, oh!
Oh yeah, yeah, now I'm not...
I was eating.
Wait, why is there a ghost here?
What's she doing here?
I don't know, I'm following her.
Donkey, you can rest people in the next game.
Oh, okay, okay, we gotta stick together.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like Apex Legends.
Okay, okay, okay, we gotta stick together.
Hear my voice.
Well...
Yeah.
Don't... I'll be screaming.
Don't worry if I die.
I'm gonna stick with Antfrost.
And you can stick with me with Antfrost.
Oh, okay, okay.
And then Antfrost will carry both of us.
Yeah.
Yeah?
Yeah, because he's so strong.
Yeah, you're so...
Oh, my God.
Antfrost, have you been working out?
Whoa!
Oh, my God!
Have you tried?
Has anyone ever told you that you might be the best Minecraft player in the server?
I mean, yes, thank you, Charlie.
You're my best friend.
Okay, I don't think this ghost leads to anything.
I don't think this ghost is leading us anywhere, by the way.
I'm just like, I don't know.
God, I keep...
Me bubby, me bubby.
Cursing on accident.
It's okay.
As long as...
You're my best friend.
As long as we...
I think it only matters if you're in the finals.
You've been going around the world.
Yeah, I don't think so, either.
I think they just added that for fun.
I think you are.
I think you're going to make it.
You're going to be fine.
I was like, what?
Are we still following the ghost?
Okay.
Guys, I don't think the ghost leads anywhere, guys.
Oh, my God.
There's so many people.
I'm getting overwhelmed.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Okay.
I need to find a corner to hide.
Sorry.
There's too many voices.
The voices.
Do you hear all those voices?
There's too many voices.
What do they say?
All right.
I'm going to eat my lunch, by the way.
I was speed running in the convention crowd.
No, man.
Oh, my God.
But, yeah.
I can't believe it.
The...
What's the word?
My will to win overpowered my rational thinking because I was just like, you know, I was like, oh, my God.
I made it to the next day.
And then, like, 30 minutes later, the realization came in.
I was like, oh, my God.
I made it to the next day.
Hey.
What is that?
Where's your allies?
I think...
Yeah.
Oh, you need an ally.
Don't you, Irab?
I apparently know where three more are.
Yeah.
Oh, are you desperate now?
I mean, we were both friends in Mendoza, so I think it's...
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
You want to be allied with a VTuber?
Is that where you're at in your life now?
I have nothing against VTubers.
Yeah.
You have nothing against VTubers?
Is that what your chat's saying, too?
Is that...
My chat does not represent me.
Oh, he doesn't represent you.
Oh, so you're saying your chat's liars, then.
My chat does not reflect me.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Well, you know, like, this game, you can res people, right?
The next game?
Yeah.
So, I got you.
You got me.
Yeah.
Right?
Okay.
So, this is the end of the video, guys.
I'll see you guys in the next one.
Bye!
Yeah, we have stamina now.
Yeah, apparently like- Oh my gosh, my fucking food.
I can't even eat my food!
God damn it!
All right, we have voice chat reconnecting in three minutes.
Oh no, I lost her.
I looked away to put my food away!
All right.
Yeah, I know E-Rob's desperate now.
He needs- He needs people.
Wait, I lost her.
Guys, where did Gumi go?
Look, I will carry E-Rob, Gumi will carry me, and then- and Frost will carry Gumi.
We'll have like a chain.
We'll have- We'll have a chain of people helping.
Where the fuck did Gumi go?
Oh, guys, guys, it's time to find Where's Gumi?
Our favorite game.
Where- Oh, there- There she is.
Nice.
Okay.
All right, the chain will start the circle.
All right.
So like- Apparently, you can res people.
And all we need to do is make sure we don't fucking die.
Or if we do die, that- that we're close to- we're close to our allies.
All right.
Let's see.
Let me- I feel like I should adjust the volume a little bit.
I'll put it at 90 because some of the volume is so fucking loud sometimes.
But also like- Let me double check if- Uh...
I gotta bring up the game volume.
Okay.
My sound guy says bring up the game volume.
Wait, there's like more stuff now.
I guess I'll bring up the music and the environment.
Okay.
I don't know if that's better.
All right, let's go.
Also, for all the new viewers here.
I usually stream on the YouTube.
So please check me out over there.
I do like the Twitch events.
The Twitch events, I stream on Twitch because, you know.
It makes sense.
The Twitch invites- Whoa!
Okay.
The voices came back, chat.
Oh, sorry.
I misread my sound guy.
He said bring it down.
I brought it back up.
There we go.
All right.
The voices came back.
I got him.
I'll unmute when the voices start slowing down.
We'll fix that later.
There's just way too many- Too many people are still alive.
Too many people are still alive for this to work.
Okay.
The voices, they're so loud.
There's like music playing.
What the fuck?
Oh my God.
Took my meds and the voices.
They're still coming.
Oh my God.
This is purgatory.
We will- We will re-enable it when the gate round starts.
I don't think- I don't think I can deal with the voices at the moment.
Okay.
So, the voices would- Guys, I forgot to take my meds.
We know I took my meds, guys.
Guys, it's working.
The meds are working.
The voices stopped.
Hahahaha.
Oh my God.
The voices- I told you, medicine works.
Oh God, E.
Robb came back.
Hahahaha.
Don't worry.
I'll - Make sure I keep taking my meds.
Alright.
We're gonna have to- We're gonna have to work together, guys.
This is a teamwork.
E.
Robb found us.
Hahahaha.
We're going to have to work... oh!
Monsters and Prey.
What's this?
I did it!
In the basement?
What the fuck?
We have to get to there.
Wait, that means eight people are going to get eliminated.
Wait, what protects me?
Oh shit.
Oh shit, ten of us?
Guys, that's going to be me.
Wait, what happens?
You will be injured and unable to move at a normal speed.
Oh, so I have to make sure I don't...
There's parkour?
Other players can heal you by crouching next to you, speeding up your recovery.
Oh no, there's parkour.
But this is not a time to rely on others.
Because it's everyone who themselves...
Oh no, not platforming.
Each of you will have a stamina meter.
It will decrease as you sprint.
And if it hits zero, you will lose the ability to sprint for three seconds.
It was a good run, guys.
It was!
Guys, it was a good run.
Now we have platforming.
Do your best to arrive in its safe zone as quickly as possible.
It was a good run.
If the gate closes before you arrive, you'll be ours forever.
The parkour is not that...
Yeah, okay, for a normal person.
Guys, I already have the VTuber debuff.
I don't know what you want from me.
Guys, I literally learned the jump tech.
Oh my god, there's Kachow!
I learned the jump tech, like, after the game was over.
Okay.
Let's see.
Where is...
Okay, we need to find...
Wait, where's Gumi?
Where's Gumi?
Where is she?
I need her to res me when I get hit.
I need her to res me.
I need to be on her backpack.
Where's the backpack?
Where...
That's not very helpful, guys.
Where the...
I don't know where...
Oh, there...
There's Gumi.
That's her.
Wait, is that her?
Is that...
Yeah!
Okay.
Doki!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We all stick together, yes?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
We stick together.
I'll save you if you save me.
Of course.
Wait, who's our group?
Who else do we get?
People that are coming over here.
We're meeting here.
Whoever's here is in our group.
Oh, okay, okay.
Yeah, we're all going to help each other out, right?
Warren, come here.
You want to join our group?
All right, guys.
Who's in this group?
All my friends.
Like, the cool people?
And if you're my friend, you would join.
All my friends are creepers.
No, you guys don't understand.
Are all your friends going to meet?
Oh, that's tough.
This is everyone?
Well, except for this guy.
This guy's not our friend.
That's crazy.
Except for that one guy over there.
He has so many friends.
I wish I had this many friends.
Hey, I wish you too, man.
I don't care who.
We need to get everybody through this.
Oh, you think so?
Well, not everybody.
Yeah, totally need to.
Because you can heal each other.
I'm saving everybody, man.
I think we need to stay near the beginning, but don't stay too close to the beginning.
Oh, okay.
So you want to like...
Like the front.
So you want to stutter, like get to the other side a little.
Yeah, let the people in the front kind of act like meat shields.
You know what I mean?
Oh, they're aggro.
They're all going to be like...
They're not dying.
They're going to be like crying.
Save us!
Save me!
And then Madge is going to run past them.
They cried out, save us.
And I said, no.
Okay, buddy.
You can save Goomy.
Wait, where's Ad?
Bye, Goomy.
I thought Ad was supposed to help us.
I'll miss you, Goomy.
All right.
I think we need to gather.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I just thought Ad was going to betray us there.
No, he would never.
I know where he lives.
Yeah, where?
I'll keep it a secret.
I'm trying to hear you.
Me and my chat will keep it a secret.
2279.
Acacia Street.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, no!
How am I supposed to...
How am I supposed to win if we don't know his address?
Oh, my God.
Two minutes.
Has it been eight minutes already?
Wait, really?
Damn.
All right.
Goomy, you wouldn't let me die, right?
We'll advance to day three together, right?
All I'm saying, Goomy, is for the fourth game, if we combine our chat's IQs together to do the puzzle, we might be able to beat one puzzle.
All right.
We might be able to solve one puzzle together.
Did you hear the lyrics?
Okay.
Let's go look for our friends.
All right.
Oh, my God.
Everybody is talking.
I found one.
All right.
Wait.
Bad Boy Halo is going to help us?
Oh, I found them.
Oh, is that the group?
Yeah.
But it's like bobbing like crazy out of it.
It was.
You abandoned us.
I was scared.
You're going to make sure we live right at...
I think it's just a bug.
Are they going to...
We've got to stick together.
Okay.
Yeah.
So, Bad Boy and his stutter like to get to the other side tunnel, too.
He wants to wait to leave a little.
Huh?
I don't know about that, either.
He said he wants to use people as meat shields, but I think the monsters reset.
They probably say in areas.
Yeah.
Maybe they're saying that so that he's going to make us slow down and he's going to be in the front.
Okay.
Why don't we all leave on the right-hand side?
Why don't we all leave to the right-hand side of the gate?
Yeah.
Turn it to zero.
Okay.
I like that.
That's a good idea.
That's it.
You got it.
You can heal each other.
Okay.
Yeah.
Stick to the right side.
Oh, one more minute.
One more minute.
Wait.
Shane, can't we build that?
Yeah.
I'm scared.
Exactly.
Oh, my God.
There's no way they're going to let us die.
Right?
Okay.
Revive me.
Yeah.
Revive me, too.
Well, we come as a couple.
Yeah.
We're like a package two for one.
A two for one deal.
Oh, my God.
There's so many people.
I'm using the stamina thing.
All right, Ambrose.
Let's go over here.
Are you running up the car?
Okay.
I'm coming over here.
Wait.
You can...
Like, hit W, and then jump, and then go over W.
And just, like, move like that.
What?
Just, like, hit W, and then jump, and then, like, let go over W.
And you sort of, like, jump along like this.
Okay.
I see.
I understand what you mean.
I'm confused.
Okay.
Let's go.
I'm confused.
Let's go to the right side.
Okay.
I'm confused.
Am I sprinting up this guy?
Oh, God!
Oh!
Here we go.
Gate opens.
The last turn!
Yeah!
Let's go!
The last turn up!
Yeah!
Where?
Where's my team?
Please, no music.
Guys, turn off the music.
Please.
It's so annoying.
Where's my team?
I don't know where my team is.
It's actually behind you.
It's behind you.
Come, come, come, come.
Is that my team?
One guy fell.
I can't see shit!
I'm stuck!
Guys, I don't know where to go!
Help!
There's too many people!
Guys!
Am I doing anything?
I don't think I can get up here.
What the fuck?
I don't know where to go from here.
This is stressful!
Guys, it's over.
It's so over.
I can't see.
Shane, are you in F5 right now?
Or what are you doing?
Let's go!
Guys, I can't see anyone!
Please get out of my face!
Tender just opened his mouth.
Guys, I don't know...
Oh wait!
It's in front of me!
Okay, guys.
I don't see you, but I think you're near me.
I see... I see steps.
Just keep communicating with me.
Just so I know you're near.
You can go under.
Where is it?
I'm so...
I'm so confused!
Oh!
He's dead!
I thought somebody died!
Oh my god!
Oh god!
Oh, F5, you're right!
Wait!
No, I can't!
Because I don't know where to look yet!
Oh my god!
He's a dead guy!
There's so many dead people!
It's okay.
If I don't look behind me...
If I don't look behind me, everything will be fine!
Okay.
We're recharging.
Okay, it's fine.
Everything is fine.
Hi, guys!
Okay, we're fine.
I hate this!
We're fine.
There's no way!
We're at the bottom!
Wait!
Alright, guys!
Oh my god!
The first save zone!
We made it!
Oh, that's the save zone!
Okay!
Save zone!
Okay, I didn't like that sound.
That sound was a little scary.
It was a little sus.
Oh, we're all in the save zone!
So we all have to wait!
We all have to wait!
I think I got something out of my mouth!
Oh my god!
Nice!
We made it, like, barely!
We made it!
We pulled that!
Oh, no!
I'm so scared!
We did it!
We all made it!
Okay!
Alright, we made it!
We made it!
It might have been, like, really fucked up, but we made it!
Oh my god!
Thank you!
Oh god!
I feel... oh god, thank you!
Finally!
Everything is nice and quiet now.
We took our beds.
Oh, thank god we took our beds!
Oh my god!
The voices are gone.
I did it!
I couldn't see what was going on!
I have to F5!
Wait, she...
Yeah, yeah, did you F5?
Yeah.
I did a bit!
Yeah, that was fucked up.
I didn't... remember that first... that first obstacle with the trees?
That shit was crazy.
I don't even know how we got there.
I think we got TP'd.
Oh my god, E-Rob, you made it!
Yeah, yeah, were you, like...
Were you, like, 107th or something?
Oh my god, we did it, guys!
Yo, we barely made it, Dr. Gluhug.
Oh my god.
It was me and you next to each other and I was like, I don't know what we're gonna do.
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
I'm asleep right now, alright?
I'm not turning off.
Oh!
I took my meds.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
Silence.
The voices are gone.
Oh, thank god.
Thank god.
Oh my god.
Guys, remember to take your meds or you're gonna have to listen to that the whole time.
Remember to take your meds, guys!
Take your meds!
Alright.
We have two more checkpoints.
I think we can make it.
We weren't in the back of the pack.
Chat.
Like, we weren't...
I think the moment I get hit by the monster, I'm fucked.
I think that's really it.
The moment the monster fucking touches me, like, it's over.
Like, it's so over.
We just shouldn't let the monsters touch me.
And we should be good.
Oh!
I feel like, yeah, there's no...
I feel like people don't revive.
Because, like, it's just so chaotic.
There's no way.
It's just so chaotic.
Oh yeah, the parkour's gonna be crazy.
The people who don't have the F5 is gonna get fucked over.
Because I could not see.
I could not see in first person at all.
Everyone's just running.
Remember to conserve your stamina.
Yeah, I need to remember to do that too.
Oh wait, it's time.
We gotta get there.
It's okay, we have peace and quiet.
I can't wait for more people.
I feel like we should be eliminating more people.
It's just...
108 is still too many people.
It's still too many.
We need to get rid of some.
Yeah, this was not meant for this many people.
I feel like maybe, like, have people each have their own parkour area.
Like, maybe divide it by 30.
And then we have 30 of these.
And then we have multiple parkour areas and have 30 people in each.
I feel like that would have been better.
Yeah.
It's just...
multiple lobbies.
This is just too much.
This actually is too much.
I mean, I cannot... I can't even see where I am right now.
Like, guys, I don't know if I should play an F5.
I can't see where my body is.
Where am I?
I'm, like, in the...
I've been, like, in the horn.
Holy shit, the game almost crashed.
I'm, like, in the fucking club.
Oh...
Where am I?
Guys...
Guys, I'm not gonna...
I don't...
Guys, I think this was a mistake, guys.
Guys, this seems to be a mistake now.
Oh, no.
Guys, I think it's over.
Guys, I'm doing worse than I actually did.
Oh, no.
I'm doing worse, guys.
Oh, no!
Oh, no, this is bad.
Okay, we gotta... we gotta do this.
I'm actually doing worse now.
We got an F5, everybody.
I can't see.
I actually couldn't see, guys.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Don't worry.
It's not over yet.
We just gotta have to make it to the second checkpoint, everybody.
The moment we make it to the second checkpoint, we'll be okay.
Oh, God.
Oh, yeah.
That was definitely a mistake.
Whoever said F5, that was a mistake.
Now we're fucked a little.
Now...
Now we're a little fucked, guys.
Okay.
Oh, I can't... I don't know how to, like, uh, make it so that...
Guys, how do you make it so I don't use my stamina accidentally?
Because...
Because, like, it won't let me cancel it.
I feel like...
I feel like I can't cancel it.
Oh, I got the one of the...
Got some...
No!
Oh, no!
Wait, do we have to do this again?
We do!
No!
My stamina!
Okay.
Alright, we're okay.
No!
We're not okay!
Slow and steady.
Slow and steady, Doki.
It's parkour!
There's people worse than you at parkour!
No!
Oh, God.
There's people back there that's worse than you at this.
It'll be fine.
Oh, God.
There's people that are so cocky when it comes to parkour!
Okay, nice.
You got this!
Do I?
No.
Oh, my God.
My stamina.
Okay.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, God.
Oh, I'm so fucked.
I'm so fucked.
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Woo!
Look behind me!
Is he behind me?
I don't wanna look!
Okay.
Oh, God.
Woo!
Fuck!
Oh, that's scary.
That was so scary.
Oh!
We're okay.
That was really scary.
But we're okay.
Oh, my God.
I just saw somebody died in front of me.
Shit.
Oh, God.
Like...
It's so scary cause like...
Oh, my hands are shaking.
I hate parkour.
Oh, guys!
This is so bad cause my hands are actually shaking!
Oh, God.
Oh!
Okay.
We gotta recharge our stamina.
Oh, God.
Oh!
My hands are shaking so much!
Oh, God.
I have to...
I'm so nervous.
So I have to like...
do it one by one.
Cause I'm so nervous.
Cause my hands are shaking so much.
Oh!
Parkour makes me so nervous.
Okay.
Everything is okay.
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, God.
I thought I couldn't see.
I couldn't see right there.
Oh!
Because like there's no way.
They just have to eliminate two, right?
There's no way I'm the last two.
I only messed up the parkour like once.
Oh, I can't see.
Why is this so long?
Why was the first one so short?
Like... Okay.
This is bullshit.
The first one was so short.
And this feels like a...
The fucking level gap between the two.
Jesus.
Ugh.
Alright.
Here you go.
Please.
I'd rather be average.
Let me be the middle of the pack.
Oh, thank God.
There's at least two people behind me.
Thank God.
There's at least...
There's at least two people behind me.
We should be fine.
Oh my God.
The fact that no one's at the safe zone yet.
It's concerning me.
No one's at the safe zone.
There's still like 200 fucking parkour.
It never ends.
It never fucking...
It's like the marathon all over.
Oh my God.
Oh no.
I hope I have allies.
I...
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay.
We got conservative stamina here.
Oh God.
I'm going left.
It was too scary so I'm gonna go left.
Oh.
I hope left is okay because I only have one person I'm following.
I'm following.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Okay.
I'm a little worried that there was only one person that was there.
Oh, I'm getting better.
Wait.
Oh God.
Someone made it.
That means there's an end.
Oh my God.
People are making it.
That means there is an ending to this.
Oh my God.
I can't believe it.
No!
Checkpoint's not that bad.
Okay.
I didn't fuck up too much.
I got scared there.
Oh God.
Here we go.
Okay.
Almost scared myself there.
I've refilled that stamina!
Oh.
Okay.
There is an ending chat!
The fact that there is an ending gives me so much hope!
Oh my God.
There is an end to this madness.
I don't like that numbers are going up.
Oh no.
I don't like that.
I don't...
Oh no.
Please tell me I can be middle of the pack.
Please.
Let me be the middle of the pack.
That's all I ask.
Oh God.
Where is everybody?
Oh.
58.
The numbers are increasing, guys!
Guys!
Wait.
Is that it?
Is that the end?
I'm 71!
Let's fucking go!
Oh!
I made it!
Oh thank God.
Oh God.
Oh I made it.
Oh.
Okay.
I'm better than like 40 people.
We had a very scuff start.
We had an incredibly scuff start.
But we still live.
The start!
Definitely could be improved by a lot.
That was...
Oh.
Yeah we had like a very rough time there.
Like that was pretty fucking rough.
Yeah.
No more F5 chat.
We've learned.
No more fucking F5 for us.
Oh.
Oh I was so stressed out.
I was so fucking stressed out there.
My hands were literally shaking.
Oh my God.
Now they have to eliminate 5 more.
Oh God.
I just can't be the last 5.
If I live.
If I just can't be the last 5.
I didn't mess up the parkour!
So we're okay.
Oh my God.
My heart.
My heart can't take these games.
Where is she?
I don't see her.
You liars.
Oh.
It's fine.
I'm just happy that I was 70 so I was like in the middle of the pack.
But she's right there.
Where?
I have to turn off because I took my meds today.
So I don't hear the voices at the moment.
I mean you'll hear her.
Guys I don't know.
I might hear her.
But I'll also hear 30 other voices.
So I don't know.
I don't know guys.
I don't really want to hear 30 other voices.
The dark corner.
Okay.
Dark corner.
Kind of like.
And then I have to let go of W.
I'm trying to remember how to look at my...
I passed it?
Oh my god.
I can't find her.
Where is she?
Are you sure?
Did you guys take your meds?
Right of the door.
Oh this is right.
Oh there she is!
Hello?
Who me?
Oh now you want to look at me you stupid...
I had it muted!
I couldn't find...
I took my meds.
So I couldn't hear the voices anymore.
I wasn't even talking to you.
I was in front of you.
You know I'm blind.
I appreciate you.
You know that.
You turned away from me twice.
Okay I don't know about that.
I don't remember that.
Your chat probably does.
Okay yes my chat was telling me where you are and I was lost.
I kept looking around.
You're hiding in the corridor.
How am I supposed to see that?
You were running back and forth here.
And then you just turned away.
I was like you know what I'm done.
I don't know.
You were in the corridor.
How was I supposed to know?
What place did you get?
I got 21st.
I made a mistake by having F5 and I bumped into everything.
I was like 70 something so I was like in the middle of the pack.
Not last.
I was alone by myself for a while.
Wait really?
That's scary.
I didn't get caught by the monsters though.
I didn't get caught either but I went on the right path.
Everyone went left so I was all alone.
Monster on the loose.
Yeah.
That was so scary when the monsters were chasing.
The dog one was scary.
The one on all fours.
Oh yeah that guy was huge.
Honestly I made shatter go in front of me.
There was a couple people waiting.
I was like I'm just going to run at it.
Wait you ran at it?
How did you live?
If you have full stamina if you just run past it it won't be able to chase you for long enough.
Oh my god it's so smart.
Minecraft tech.
Guys why couldn't you give me that Minecraft tech?
There's so many of you.
One of you guys could have given me that advice.
One last person.
That must be so scary.
Yeah.
When everyone started coming into the game I was like oh my god I'm all alone.
Who got eliminated?
Look at the scene.
I feel like it's so embarrassing that they put your name up at the top.
Oh Darryl this guy got eliminated.
Oh no.
Look at those people getting eliminated.
Not us.
As long as it's not us.
See that person I could have picked them up and I didn't.
Let's go.
High fives.
Up top.
Maybe you are a bad boy.
I am.
I didn't pick up any randoms.
Wait if it wasn't me would you pick me up?
Yeah if it was you I would.
I would be behind you.
You have to turn around.
You're all not turning around.
You're not turning around for me?
I'll pick you up.
See okay wait yeah I will do it.
Well Dokie here's the problem.
I think all of us are usually ahead of you.
One place.
Yeah but you'll turn around right?
Yeah totally.
Yeah you'll turn around right?
Yeah.
Girl how are you going to play?
I'm going to call you on discord if you don't pick me up.
I'm on do not disturb at all times.
You have my phone number.
Yeah I'm going to call you on your I'll call you on your number.
Just remember I'll call you on your phone number to pick me up.
I'll call you on your phone number to pick me up.
I'm going to mute again there's too many voices.
Dude just come over here.
Yeah but they... but the gates.
That's where...
There's three minutes look at the timer.
But the gates.
Show mama.
Oh woah.
It's a nice party.
Oh my god that parkour shit stressed me out so much.
It was so... my hands were shaking.
Oh I just stopped sprinting after each jump and then I had full stamina the entire time.
Yeah but it was just so stressful.
Were you F5-ing the entire time?
Is that why?
No.
I was like...
I was first person.
After I played it F5 in the beginning it was such a mess because I couldn't see where I am so I just played first person.
I felt... I feel like this one this next one or the last one will have a lot more monsters.
Because I feel like this one was parkour heavy.
Yeah.
100%.
I'm pretty sure this one is also parkour because there was like the one with the lava in the cutscene.
We already did the lava.
No no the full lava though.
There was like a lot more lava though.
Wasn't it?
Yeah.
I feel like we just did that one.
I feel like I didn't see the other lava area but maybe.
How many people are you eliminating for this one?
10 in total.
So they're eliminating 2 each safety round.
So this one is 2 then.
So 4 people have been eliminated already.
Oh okay nevermind 6.
It might be 8 people.
8?
Guys.
Do you automatically get up if no one picks you up or are you stuck behind?
I think so.
It just takes a while.
Oh so we can just leave people behind then.
No no no no no no.
You leave certain people behind but you'll pick me up.
Got it.
Certain people leave behind.
Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah.
Certain people.
Yeah leaving certain people behind.
Yeah yeah yeah but not us.
Certain people behind.
Not us.
If you don't pick me up.
Gumi will be mad.
Alright.
Is that true Gumi?
Gumi?
Gumi we're a package deal.
You said we're a package deal Gumi.
What happened?
I think I understand what's going on.
Don't get betrayed by them.
I just heard something and that's all I hear.
Got it.
Don't get betrayed by them.
I'm not picking up certain people.
We know who we're not trusting.
Don't get betrayed by them.
I misheard the overhearing.
No.
They're telling me to save them.
We should head over.
Alright.
Now I took my meds again.
Pure silence.
It's okay.
I see your colors baby.
I took the wrong meds.
I took the wrong one.
Why?!
I'm here.
We're back.
Woooo!
Wait.
Where to go?
I...
I guess here?
Oh god.
I can't see.
I hope front was the right way to go.
That's what I hope for.
I'm not using all my stamina, guys!
I'm actually learning!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, who was that?
Who was that?
Who was that, guys?
Don't look behind!
If you don't turn around and look, you won't get hurt.
Guys, I can learn.
I told you guys.
I told you guys I can learn.
I figured it out, guys!
I figured out how to conserve my stamina!
If I let go all the buttons, eventually I'll have my stamina.
Eventually I stop, guys.
I just gotta let everything go.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Oh god.
Oh, I hear people behind me!
It's okay.
There's so many people that got caught.
I didn't even see the monster!
That was the scary part!
I didn't even see the monster there!
Yay!
Conserving my stamina.
Oh!
We're okay.
Guys, it only took two save zones to learn how to play this game.
God, Minecraft is so easy.
It's a fucking game for babies.
Sorry!
Holy shit!
I think somebody died in front of me!
Oh my god!
I'm pretty sure someone literally died in front of me!
Oh my god, that was so close!
Holy fuck, that was actually so close!
Holy shit!
Guys, I think...
It's okay, we're okay.
Watch your tone!
Don't ever call Minecraft.
I'm sorry, Minecraft's not a game for babies.
I'm so sorry.
It's a game for adults.
For 18 plus and over.
But like, not that type of...
Woo!
But not that...
I'm 18!
I did it!
Oh my god!
I was ahead of going!
Oh shit.
Boo!
I was...
Come here!
Ducky!
I was ahead of you!
Let's go, let's go!
No, Ducky!
I've been standing here!
No, I got you!
I was a player!
I've been standing in front of you!
You made it!
Oh my god!
We did it guys!
We fucking did it!
We're so good!
18!
Let's go!
Oh my god.
Guys, is this what it's like to be a fucking winner?
Oh my god!
I'm a... winner?
I'm not last!
Let's go!
Oh my god, guys!
Oh, Warren TV!
Yeah, fuck you!
You fucked me over yesterday!
Yeah, that's right, Warren TV!
You lied to me yesterday!
That's called karma!
Oh my god!
I don't think I forgot about yesterday!
I'm a pro at Minecraft, dude.
There you go.
I told you karma was gonna happen.
Karma's a bitch.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna wake up.
I'm gonna wake up from this nightmare.
Oh my god.
Why was this one so goddamn short compared to what we... like, what?
Why was this one so goddamn short?
Okay.
Alright, turning down master and bringing everything down.
Okay, we're gonna have to...
Okay, we're gonna have to bring down the master volume because we have no idea what is anything tied to.
So we're gonna bring down the master volume.
We're like trying to figure out what is making the... like the ambient noises.
And like...
What is making the ambient noises and the monster noises?
So we've been trying to figure it out.
We've been turning everything down but it's not working!
Like I don't understand!
Nothing was working!
Alright.
Okay, we're just gonna turn up the voice then.
We tried the weather, right?
Maybe.
It could be the weather actually.
Okay, we're gonna turn the weather down.
But...
Is this volume too low?
Was it too loud when we were playing?
I couldn't tell.
Honestly.
Because like...
Sound guy was saying that the monsters were being too loud.
So I wasn't sure.
It was fine?
Yeah, it was.
It's all over...
Yeah, it is pretty all over in the place.
Yeah.
It was immersive.
True!
True.
It was immersive.
It was so immersive.
Guys, see?
Every game we learn more about how to play this game.
We learn more and more about how to play.
We're getting better chat.
We're getting better at Minecraft.
Because Minecraft is not a baby game.
That was so fucked up.
I called...
Somebody died in front of me the moment I called Minecraft a baby game.
That was so fucked up.
I'm like, I'm sorry.
I didn't mean it.
I'm like, where did the monster come from?
Dude.
Yeah, Minecraft should be an esport.
There should be a Bed Wars esport.
The views will go insane.
God struck them for my sins.
God...
Okay, look guys.
God's aim is a little bit wonky, guys.
Okay?
He's not a game...
God is not a gamer, guys.
Alright?
He sort of missed...
I don't know.
He just missed, okay?
But he taught me a lesson.
Now I know.
Never should talk Minecraft.
No, next game is like a puzzle.
It's a puzzle game.
So like, as long as...
Chat, you gotta help me backseat this, okay, guys?
Guys, you gotta...
You gotta help me backseat.
I believe.
I'll wait.
Hopefully.
He's still alive.
I can't believe he's still alive.
Where's Goomy?
We gotta combine our chats together.
Because if we average...
If we average our chat's IQs together, it'd be like two.
Two brain cells.
And include Goomy and I.
Because like, Goomy and I, we add our brains together, it'd be like 0.1.
But if we add your chat and my...
Like, her chat and my brain cells, it'd be like 0.1.
But if we add my chat together, it'd be like 2.
So you guys are like 1.8.
Alright, we got...
We can do this.
If we put all our brains together, we can do this, guys!
There's no way!
Alright, let's see who has...
Look at all these dead bodies.
Oh my god.
Look at all these...
That's me.
I'm still alive, bitches.
I'm still alive.
But Doki, we have no brains.
Yep, you have like 0.01%.
So you add it all together, it would be a 2.
Guys, it's a puzzle!
We know me and puzzles, guys!
All you puzzle dragons who keep telling me to play a puzzle game!
This is your time to rise up!
Chat.
Literally, whenever you guys are like, Doki, please play a puzzle game!
Play like those...
Like, I can do this!
I can do this!
Guys, play that...
Play that IQ...
Like, what was it?
The one where you have to draw lines or whatever to solve the puzzle?
This is your chance to rise up and backseat me!
It was like, Doki, play a little to the left!
Doki, play!
Doki, play a detective game!
Doki!
This is it.
This literally is it.
It's literally your moment to shine.
I'm too lazy to do puzzles.
It's okay, we can do this.
I believe.
Like, there's no way.
It's like, we all work... we have... it's like each...
Some people don't even have a chat to help them, guys.
They have to use their own brains.
That's why... that's why we're working together.
We literally have chat advantage.
And like, the best part is that... I'm sorry to all the Minecraft viewers.
Like, it's not you guys.
Minecraft viewers that are watching me, this doesn't pertain to you.
This does not apply to you.
But what's the best part is that we're not Minecraft viewers.
Our main category is not Minecraft.
So the... so the average age of a dragoon is at least over 13.
So, we have a chance against the other Minecraft players.
So we can do it, guys!
But like, if you're a Minecraft viewer and you're watching me, this doesn't apply to you.
Because you're watching me, so your age is already like...
Gumi!
Wait, where are you, Gumi?
Gumi?
Oh wow, it feels better.
Where's Gumi?
Am I hearing voices again?
Where did Gumi go?
Where is she?
Did I imagine that?
You guys heard it too, right?
You guys heard it?
You guys heard that voice, right?
Did you not hear what I heard?
Guys?
Did you not hear... hear... Gumi?
Oh no.
Guys, I think I'm...
Oh, Gumi!
Gumi!
I see you running, Gumi!
I know you're there.
I know you're in front of me, Gumi.
Gumi, where are you going?
Gumi?
She's losing...
Gumi, what are you doing?
Hey!
Gumi!
Why did you catch up so fast?
I did it.
I learned the Minecraft tech.
I was 18th place.
Are you proud of me?
I am proud.
I was ahead of you.
Yeah.
Are you proud of me?
I became the master.
I am proud.
I am.
Yeah.
Yeah, it only took me two save points.
We need...
We need to do puzzles.
Yeah, yeah.
So your chat and my chat can work together in solving this puzzle.
Yeah.
Right?
And...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Because they said emote only isn't on.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Surely.
Yeah, so we can backseat.
We're allowed to get some help.
Oh, and then like...
If our chat can look at...
God.
Oh, my God.
No.
I already know what you're gonna say.
I mean, people are ahead of us.
You two in this room over here?
It's a joke, guys.
You guys didn't know.
That's a joke, guys.
It's a disclaimer.
Don't do it.
It's a joke, guys.
Don't do it, guys.
Guys, we're just joking.
We're going to use our brains.
We're not going to use other people's brains.
We're going to use our brains together.
And chat's brains, but like with no outside help other than that.
So I don't know what... Oh wait, there's 20 Easter eggs now?
Wait, what?
I was not paying attention.
What are the other Easter eggs look like?
They're TVs again.
Oh, they're more TVs?
Yeah, I found nine of them already, Doki.
Oh.
Here, there's one right here.
Oh, they added more TVs.
Oh, I wonder what we get for 20 eggs.
I got 18.
I'm at 18 as well.
I'm at 17.
What one am I missing that you're at?
Did you get the one behind the stairs?
Yeah, I got the one behind the stairs.
I live in Buckingham Palace.
Where's the others?
Wait, there's one upstairs?
Wait, wait, wait.
There's TVs upstairs?
Nah, this is going to be troll.
I did not say this.
Who said this?
There's a TV in one of the bedrooms.
I searched all six bedroom sections.
I didn't see one.
It was like next to a bed.
You just lied.
Hey, there could be.
That lie around is so fake.
I mean, hey, if there was one, then they found an egg.
No, no, no.
Not like that, no.
There's no reason.
There's always a reason, chat.
There's always a reason.
Toki, wow.
Joke keeper.
Toki, I couldn't find one out here.
Yeah, I couldn't.
I like how you knew I was lying when I talked about the bedroom TV.
Yeah.
Well, honestly, I didn't even hear you, but I would have known either way.
Yeah, I mean, I just found out about the TV.
So, yeah.
Oh, no, it's time.
We gotta work together.
He was the only one that didn't run to the bedrooms.
It's joke keeper time.
I can't believe it.
I said that and everybody ran to the fucking...
Ran to the fucking bedroom.
Ain't no way.
Let me find it.
That's so funny.
What?
What's this?
There's a farm.
Oh, we've been here.
Isn't this...
To be fair, this looks like...
La Granja.
This looks like the...
This literally looks like the fucking first map.
Where is he going?
He just ran past a familiar face.
Where did he go?
Oh, come on.
Oh, hey.
There's pictures there.
Oh.
There's a lot of pictures there.
Silence.
Oh, thank god.
Nice.
We did it, guys.
We're free.
Guys, I'm running out of meds, guys.
I don't have... I don't have health insurance, guys.
I can't keep... I can't keep taking them.
We're gonna run out of meds soon.
Guys, guys, I don't wanna have an addiction, guys.
Buy more.
Guys, what if I get addicted to it just like painkillers?
Guys, I don't wanna be those painkillers, guys.
Hello.
Dude, I was talking about how you actually saw me.
What?
And how rare it is.
Yeah, I saw you.
You're like a dinosaur.
Oh my god, evolving.
You only see things that move.
Yeah, that's true.
Yeah.
That's true.
If you don't move, I don't see you.
You're like becoming a human being almost.
I see via...
I see you almost.
Heat vision.
I look via heat vision and like movement.
So if you don't move...
You're like a human being.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm like...
I think it's the side effects from the meds I'm taking.
Every time I take it, the voices disappear.
Oh, I let my voices go.
You go wild?
Right now, the voices are going...
Beedee do do do do.
Beedee do do do do do.
Wait, I don't think that's healthy.
What?
I don't think...
I don't think that's healthy, goon.
And the other one's going...
Dum dum dee doo ee.
Dum dum dee doo ee dum.
Bum.
Ba da da.
Wait, then how do you hear...
Oh!
Wait, how do you hear regular people?
Maybe you're listening...
Hearing the voices.
It gets transcribed.
Like there's a...
There's like a text description.
There's a little lag.
Yeah, subtitles underneath the music.
So while you're talking, I hear, like, Nightcore in my right ear, Hamster's song in my left ear.
Oh my god, you hear the Eurovision song, Nightcore?
Yeah, that Eurovision song was...
You know that song is actually from Eurovision?
Yeah, I know, I know.
That didn't even win, right?
That didn't even win Eurovision.
Yeah, you guys don't know, Rockefeller...
Yeah, Rockefeller Feet, I honestly thought it was an American song.
I thought Rockefeller was an American song.
But it's actually a Eurovision song.
And I don't think it even won Eurovision.
And the only reason why it's popular is because of Nightcore.
It's only popular because of Nightcore.
I don't know, I was thinking about Rockefeller as in the Rockefeller Street.
You know, the Rockefeller building in New York City.
Yeah, it was Estonia.
It was from fucking Estonia!
That was like the country I least expected Rockefeller to be from.
Because all I could think about is the Rockefeller building.
The Rockefeller building in New York City.
She was second to last in Eurovision?
Oh my god, Rockefeller was second to last?
To be fair, that song...
That song is like the most popular song during that year too.
I didn't know that.
I thought it would be at least popular than that.
Like who the fuck won Eurovision during that time?
To be fair...
Alright, I think everybody knows Eurovision is sort of like...
It's not really about the song to be fair.
Eurovision has never really been about the song.
The quality of the song.
It's about...
It's about knowing which country is your ally.
Like...
Yo master's the only one that knows your country.
Dude, that's really it.
It's like, I'm friends with that country, I don't care how shitty this song is, but you're my friend.
It's just like, it's just a show you guys who's friends with who.
Oh, I'm missing strategy talks?
Oh shit!
I was jumping around!
Wait, where is Goomy's...
Okay, Mew4Me is not a strategy talk.
That's all I'm saying, guys.
I don't know...
We're out of the basement, guys.
The House of Nightmares, and now there are 100 of you left.
The next challenge is one of The Conjurer's favorite nightmares.
You will soon find yourself on a movie set.
What?
The houses, the furniture, and even the cows on the farm are all part of a fake set, which The Conjurer oversees personally.
You will be given basic instructions...
This is not a puzzle.
It looks like baking cakes and brewing simple potions.
Guys, this is not a puzzle.
Quite everyone has completed the challenge.
The curse will be cast upon the last person to successfully finish the previous challenge.
In this challenge, your goal is to avoid being infected by The Conjurer...
The puzzle, bake a cake?
...for the duration of the two-minute timer.
You can pass the curse to other players by tagging them.
If you are infected when the timer hits zero, your soul will forever belong to us.
The last set of players to complete each task will be eliminated.
Oh god, that's gonna be me, guys.
That's gonna be me!
Task one.
The last player will be eliminated.
That's gonna be me!
Task two.
The last player will be eliminated.
Oh god, this is gonna be me.
Task three.
The last two players will be eliminated.
Goodbye, guys.
We had a good run.
Task four.
The last three players will be eliminated.
That's gonna be me!
What the fuck?
Yeah, the...
Goodbye, everybody.
That's a lot of people.
What happened from, like, ten to, like, fucking two hundred?
Today.
So.
Do as the conjurer says.
And do it fast.
Or your soul shall join the house of nightmares for eternity.
Yeah, this is...
We had a good run.
You know what?
We had such a good run.
That run...
I mean, we made it this far.
Nobody expected me to be...
To last round three.
Guys.
Nobody expected it.
Wait, where's my team to strategize?
Oh.
It did look like there's...
Well...
Did it?
It kinda looks like there's teams, right?
I'm integrating into...
Okay.
I don't know.
Wait, I actually...
Yeah, are they gonna divide us randomly?
I don't think so.
Or do it like they did yesterday?
I think everyone's on the same map.
Yeah.
It's 15 eliminations from...
I don't think they know I just got here.
Five eliminations from the curse.
So we just need to all be together.
And, like...
Wait.
Okay.
Honestly, once you finish a task, I would get...
I would get away from it and go hide somewhere.
Yes.
Once you do it, it kinda goes task by task, right?
You do the task and then someone gets eliminated.
You do it, then we run.
I believe so.
If it is separate groups, I don't think it would be.
I think it will be.
No, that's too many people.
It was, like, one, one, two, three, four, four.
Only eliminate 20 people?
That's way too many to be split up.
Because it's, like, 15 per group at that point.
Well, one in...
I think it's gonna be one in five for each group gets eliminated.
So if they do five teams at a time, it means two people will get eliminated.
Guys, how do I make a cake in Minecraft, guys?
Guys, how do I make a cake in Minecraft?
Wait.
Oh, you're so mean.
And then, like, half is fixed.
We're gonna be doing potions, right?
That's what I mean.
Oh, sorry.
That's why I think they're gonna do batches of teams.
Guys, how do I do it?
Okay, so for potions, all you do is you do nether wart and then you do whatever you need to get the effect that you want.
I think the recipe will be there, because there's no way they're gonna do it.
And if I tell you the recipe, they've given us a...
Guys, how do I make potions?
Because I've never made a potion before.
How do you...
Yeah, I was right.
So whoever gets, like, the slowest gets eliminated, and then, like, the next valid person that The person that would be last to finish is gonna get the curse, so you just get out as soon as you're done.
So you make your teams, and then you compete against your team again?
I don't think it's a team, I think it's everybody on the same map.
It's everyone on the same map.
It's 100% everyone on the same map.
8 year olds, guys!
8 year olds, rise up!
We need you to help me make a cake and improve potions!
It is a lot, that's really overwhelming.
2 minutes too, that's so long.
Now's the time to take a shot to eliminate, just go grab the curse.
I thought you were gonna say take a shot, like alcohol, and I'm like I'll bet.
That's crazy.
Alexa, how do you make a cake in Minecraft?
So is it better to be with friends, or not with friends?
What do you think?
If I somehow get the curse, can you let me tag you so you can chase someone cause I'm not as fast?
In theory, none of us should be cursed.
Can I tag you so you can tag him?
No.
What?
What happened to our package deal?
Wait, so does everybody play hot potato?
Yes.
There'll be 1 person out of 100, so you just gotta be lucky.
At that point, you're gonna lose.
At that point, you just gotta get away from the last people, it seems like.
Just outrun them.
I don't know if there's a delay in passing it.
I think there's not a delay, so you could also just go to the end and punch.
In theory, a sweat won't have the potato, and if they do, something terribly wrong happens.
Yeah, they're gonna wait till the last second and punch someone.
We should probably walk over to the entrance.
I mean, is this the entrance over here?
Yeah.
Oh, 2 minutes.
2 minutes.
I'm scared, guys.
We at the bottom, 1 egg with 2 sugar on each side for the minute.
And 3...
Guys, okay, the moment we get the cake, I need you guys to spam that.
I need you guys to spam that.
So when you have the stuff for the cake, you can just click it.
No, there's no emote only.
There's no emote only for today.
Alright, good luck, guys.
Good luck, good luck.
Okay, so you open your inventory and you see where, like, your shield would go, like, your offense.
So slightly to the right of that, you click, and does it open your crafting menu?
Yeah?
We have a crafting menu?
Slightly to the right.
You'll find it.
Yeah, click, like, a little, like, a little bit to the right of where your offhand is in your inventory.
How do I...
Slightly to the right.
How do we open our inventory?
You see at the top left, there's, like, a, there's, like, a red X, like, next to the thing on the right.
How did he open?
Oh my god!
You wanna click that, and so it says, showing craftable with the checkmark.
And then once you get the stuff for a cake, it'll tell you how to, like, it'll, like, literally just, you just click on it and it'll make it for you.
Yeah, then you can just click it.
We gotta go, guys.
We need to walk over there.
Wait, what did he teach them?
I forgot!
I forgot what I had, but Minecraft is still dying!
How can you forget?
It's been so long!
We didn't...
Where are you?
I don't know, but people got eliminated.
A Minecraft player got eliminated on the first day.
You gotta follow my voice, Fulham?
No, no, I wanna hear it louder, louder, louder.
Hello, hello, Fulham.
Right click on the shield?
There's nothing on the shield.
Meow meow meow meow meow meow meow meow meow Stop meowing, you creeps!
Stop it!
Meow meow meow meow meow meow meow meow Meow!
Oh.
Oh,
God, oh, God.
Where's my tag?
Find fuel at the fuel power for the generator?
I hope these guys are heading to the generator.
Wait, did I...
Near the farmer's house.
Oh, okay.
I got confused.
Everybody was clicking.
Oh, Eram didn't bring...
Run,
run, run.
Oh, I ran.
Confused.
Everything was so confusing.
Oh my god.
We gotta run, we gotta hide.
Run, run.
Oh my god, people are trying to camouflage.
I like how people are trying to camouflage right now.
Oh my god, there's still like three people that have it.
What the fuck?
The fuck is that?
Okay.
Alright.
How is there still like three people that haven't done...
There's still like three people that haven't done the thing.
Yeah!
I like this spot.
There's no way they can't parkour this.
Oh wait, hold on.
Up there.
Hold on.
Ooh.
Yeah, wait a minute.
Yo, yeah, shift back here for the tag section.
Look out, look out, look out, look out, look out.
They won't find us, really.
Wait.
We're fine, we're fine, guys.
We're fine, we're fine.
Oh, wait.
No.
No, I wanted to...
It's a bit of alarming that Feinberg and Prefire left.
Oh, who is it?
Oh, someone got eliminated.
And tied until the next one begins.
Aspic.
No way.
This is such a good hiding spot, guys.
This is such a good hiding spot.
Good job.
Oh, I see them over there.
They're hiding.
Whoa.
What the fuck?
La TNT.
Oh, no.
Oh, what?
Oh.
Run!
Oh, God.
Where are we running?
They're over there.
They're behind us.
Run!
Okay, there's a...
I don't know where she is.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
I don't know where she is.
I don't know where they are.
I hope she die.
Yo, guys.
I think she is like directly behind us.
Are they behind me?
I can't tell.
I'm so scared.
They're behind me.
I'm just going to keep running because I don't know.
There's no upstairs?
No.
No way I'm here.
No way I'm staying here.
Wait.
Can we see the motherfucker through walls?
Yeah, yeah.
We'll see them.
We'll see them through walls.
It's not.
Everybody's silent.
Wait.
Do we see them?
I'm scared.
I haven't seen them at all.
Where are they?
Can't.
I can't.
Wait.
Do the motherfuckers with COVID fast enough?
No.
Brad, you're cracked.
I'm cracked.
Well, yeah.
You're awesome.
I am very much cracked.
Probably shouldn't hide in the house.
Shh.
Everybody's in the house.
They're all in the house.
Come in the house.
Are we outlying?
You little bitch.
Cory Wayne.
What are you doing, bro?
Come up.
Come.
I think we can see them through the walls.
Is it like an outline or what kind of glow is it?
Yeah, it's an outline.
Why don't we see it?
I hear a heartbeat.
Does everybody hear that?
Yeah, it's getting like a bustle.
Ah, there's ladders.
I'm scared.
Guys, I'm scared.
How?
How do you get up there?
Back, back, back.
Guys, I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Thank God I speak Spanish.
Come, come, come here.
They're saying they're coming.
Hide, hide, hide.
Are you serious?
Maptor!
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Collect water from the crate near the water well.
Collect the water well.
Where's the water well?
Yeah, where is the water well?
I don't know.
Where's the water well, Reggie?
Oh no.
There's water bottles inside the house, inside of the fridge.
Inside the fridge.
I don't trust you, man.
In the farm, in the farm, in the farm.
I'm going to keep it real with you.
I'm going to keep it $1.50.
I do not trust you.
Wait, it's in the house, guys.
Go get it.
Collect sugar.
Wait, actually, where is it?
Oh, this is the water.
Where is it?
I'm so scared.
I don't know.
Is that a sugar cane over there?
Oh my God, please tell me that it is.
What if the sugar is coming from like a...
Please tell me that it is.
I'm just following the crowd.
Where's the water bottle?
See?
Oh, I got it.
You can just grab it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where's the nether wart farm?
Where's the nether wart?
Oh, I see.
I see the nether wart.
Yeah, where's the nether wart?
Where's the nether wart?
Oh, yeah, that's this way.
Where are we going?
How do we get it?
Left hand.
The nether wart's this way?
Okay.
It's by the fuel tower.
Oh, it's over there.
How do I grab the sugar?
Don't go in here.
Oh, the nether wart followed the crowd.
You guys, where's nether wart?
Oh, they were right there.
There it is.
Where's nether wart?
In the house.
Go to the house.
Where'd you guys get the water?
Oh, I'm so screwed.
Where'd you get the water?
Please?
Yay!
Wait, where's the water?
From the cabinet.
I'm just going to follow.
Do you have the water?
I'm going to follow.
Yeah, I'm going to follow.
Are you going to the powder?
Yes, I am going to the powder.
Okay.
Okay, I follow you.
There's a giant door that leads to the middle of it.
I don't know where the water is.
Where's the water?
Oh, where's Clutch?
He doesn't know where the water is.
I don't have water.
Yeah, where's the cabinet?
Over here.
Oh.
Gumi, where are you?
Guys, where's the cabinet?
Guys.
I don't know.
Chicken coop.
Where's the water?
To go there.
Who?
An awkward potion?
Go to the barn.
The barn.
Chicken coop.
Oh, I didn't know it said that.
Wait, was that a chicken coop over there?
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure the barn is a chicken coop.
Gumi, are you going to brood the chicken coop?
Chicken coop.
Inside of The Barn.
Ready to break in the barn?
Right there.
Where's the chicken coop?
Where's the chicken?
Is it in the house?
Yeah, I think it's in the house, right?
Where's the chicken coop?
Where's the water?
I don't know where the chicken coop is.
There's something swarming up there.
I don't know how to get the water.
Where's the chicken coop?
I don't know about the chicken coop.
Guys, where is the chicken coop?
Is that it?
That's the chicken coop!
That's where everybody is!
That's where all the chickens are!
Sugar first!
No, no, no, sugar first.
How do I, how do I prove it?
Sugar first!
Do not put sugar first!
Guys, wait, what?
Really?
Yeah.
Where's the conjurer?
Sugar is first.
What the fuck is a conjurer?
What?
Lace, top, left?
Hey, man, get a uno!
And then what?
And then I put sugar?
What happens after the sweet punch?
Go to the conjurer.
Where's that?
Wait, fire.
lived Like a juicio de agua.
And then I put sugar?
Oh, juicio de agua?
No la negruar, no.
Get her mind writing.
No.
More a la negruar.
No, no, no only for the mug meat.
Oh, put it...
This is why we put sugar?
Okay, we have to get another bottle of water, Flex, right?
No, no, no, I already have a bottle.
Oh, God.
Is that big?
Where's the counter?
This big guy right here?
False, it's the big guy.
It's the big guy.
To the left.
Big guy to the left.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Hi, big guy.
Hi.
Yes!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yay!
I lived!
Ideal.
Oh, my God.
It was so stressful.
From left to right.
I think we're going to save by...
Oh.
It's fine.
When we were getting Leatherwort, someone was getting water, so we're fine.
Wait, where's milk?
Do we have to go to the cows and milk today?
Oh, that was so stressful.
There's going to be Jake next to...
I see a cow right there.
Yeah, there's a cow over there.
There's another one with milk there.
Sonic, come here!
Guys, I feel like I'm going to die from the curse.
I think I'm going to die from the curse.
I want to see.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
And then eggs over there, and then sugar over there.
Eggs over there, sugar there, wheat there, milk there.
Where's the cow?
It's in the farm.
Oh, I see it.
Yeah.
Maybe we should stand right next to him while everyone's getting their stuff, no?
Well, I feel like we should like...
Well, nonetheless, standing here is good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is where everything is.
Every mob that's around is there for a reason.
So I kind of want to just take care of them.
Like, what is that right there?
Your objective.
Is that a cow?
Yeah, there's a cow over there.
Is that a sheep?
No, that's a sheep.
It looks like a sheep.
Where's the wheat?
How do we get into the wheat?
There's a door over there.
Yeah, there's an entrance over here.
Yeah?
Yeah, let's look at it together.
Yeah, let's look at the entrances.
This one over here looks like it's going to be...
An archery test.
FPS.
Yeah.
I think it's going to be good if we like...
Oh, this is bad.
I don't know how to do archery in Minecraft.
Just imagine triple take.
There's a bullet drop off.
Okay.
Follow, follow, follow.
Bro, are you just...
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm high rolling by the...
I'm high rolling standing by the chest over there.
This is the cow.
We got to get the wheat.
Wait, that's not a real cow.
It's a human.
I feel like you just...
Yeah, I just want to...
I just want to know where it is though.
Like I want to know...
No, look at his face.
That's not a real cow.
That can't be a cow.
I don't know.
Yeah, but he could be like a costume.
Wait.
Dude, you can get on the walls just like...
Wait, these are all freaks.
There's no way.
There's like a head.
There's no way that's a cow.
It looks like a human cow.
It looks like some homunculus shit.
Wait, that's a cow.
It's a sheep also like that?
Hey, don't judge.
What the fuck?
They all have those eyes.
Those creepy eyes.
The man cow bear.
They all have those eyes.
What the fuck is wrong with her?
What is wrong...
They all look like they have PTSD.
No, it's better.
They all have...
They all look like they have PTSD.
They all look like they have PTSD or some shit.
Oh, come on up.
Insane.
What?
Little cheats again.
We got a parkour legend here.
How do we even get up there?
Oh my god.
Like, they just look like they are traumatized about something.
They like...
They've seen things.
See?
Yeah.
We just ran off.
Don't put sugar free.
Oh my god.
I feel like some people got fucked over.
I feel like some people got fucked over because they put sugar first.
Holy shit.
God, I'm nervous.
Being alive.
I don't know.
I don't know if it's good to be, like...
like to live past this right now for the objective.
cause, like, I'm getting more stressed the more...
the more tasks we get, I'm getting more stressed out.
If I was limited to one, I would...
I could be chillin' right now.
Holy shit, I'm so... like I'm actually so scared.
That's okay, we're gonna be transported when the curse starts.
When the curse starts, we're gonna be transported so it doesn't matter.
Oh, there's like cows here too.
We're gonna have to find the bucket.
You know damn well that 70k is going to a fucking Minecrafter, guys.
You know that, chat.
There's no way a regular person is gonna get that 70k.
Minecrafters have been playing Minecraft games for years.
It's been 20... it's been almost 20 years since Minecraft came out.
Some of these Minecraft streamers have been streaming Minecraft since like it came out, guys.
Loser talk.
Yeah, sure.
Surefour, why aren't you in here?
That was 70k.
That could've been an easy 70k for you, Surefour.
Why aren't you here?
A hundred and fifty people?
Guys, oof.
That's an oof-er.
Right there, Surefour.
I can't believe it.
They asked SK.
And they didn't ask you?
Sleepy and Warren were...
Sleepy, Warren, and Menda were here.
Man.
Is it like... no, it's individual.
It's like an individual shit.
It's okay.
Sleepy, Warren... all the Overwatch players got eliminated, by the way, though.
Oh, yeah.
Every Overwatch player that got in got eliminated, man.
You could've been the one that lived.
You could've been the last remaining Overwatch player.
Oh, no.
How awful.
That could've been you.
Oh, yeah.
We should...
We should be in the middle.
Oh, yeah.
We gotta be in the middle.
We're gonna teleport out soon.
I forgot about that.
That's why you guys wanted me to be out of the fields.
Oh, my God.
E-Rob was 96?
Yeah, I need...
Yeah, I forgot.
I need to be all the way over there.
Oh, this is scary.
Please.
Please, 97.
Give me a...
Give me a sec to join the...
the crowd.
Let me...
Guys, I'm lost.
No!
Oh, no!
I'm fucked!
Guys!
I fucked myself over.
No!
I fucked myself over!
I'm not with the crowd!
Guys, I don't know how to get out of here!
Oh, no.
Oh, no, guys.
Oh, there's the crowd.
There's the crowd.
Oh, man.
Oh, yeah.
I got it.
Oh, no!
Oh, God.
Cause he's behind us.
Oh, I see him.
I see him.
I'm going this way.
I see them.
I'm following these guys.
It's so over.
I didn't know where I was.
Oh, my God.
Gun shift.
Shift and...
Bro, don't shift.
Don't shift.
Your arm is sticking out.
Based on what?
Don't shift.
Your arm is sticking out.
Don't shift!
What?
Punch forward.
Punch.
Punch to not stick up.
Just punch.
Just punch in front.
To not stick up.
All right.
Can we still see them glowing?
This is an insane spot, bro.
Yeah.
It's going to be so busted next time, bro.
Get that chicken head out of there.
Move your heads.
Oh, it's coming!
I'm joking.
Why do you guys think this is funny?
I don't wanna say that, bro.
Shh.
Shift?
And they're like, don't shift?
And I was like, oh, shift!
Don't move, don't move!
No, no, no, no.
Don't move.
Don't worry, the Spanish Minecrafters know what they're doing!
The Spanish Minecrafters know what they're doing!
No, no, no, no.
Of course they do!
My crafter's very popular over there!
Look at Quackity!
Freddy, come with us, Freddy.
The fucking head!
Come with us, Freddy.
Freddy Pusper.
Oh, he's behind you!
Oh, he's right behind me, isn't he?
Nice.
Oh, he did it.
Oh, god.
Find a note at the farmer's house.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where are we?
Gumi, where's the farm?
Gumi!
Gumi, I'm right behind you!
Gumi's not slowing down, guys!
Gumi!
No, it's because of the language.
They get it.
Because Gumi's not slowing down.
They're not slowing down for me!
Wrong house!
Dude, I got so bad spawn.
That was such a bad spawn.
Go to the fuel tower, go to the fuel tower.
Wait, is it the right house?
Fuel tower, they sent fuel.
Is that not the right house?
Sophie?
Yeah, they're trolling.
Wait, it's the right house?
Aw, Doki run!
I'm running, I didn't know!
They were trapping me!
You can't run.
Is he in the house?
Oh my god, we were just at the bottom.
That's so cool.
Wait, where is it?
I don't know.
Desk?
Over here?
Wait, where's the desk?
Right here!
Wait, where is it?
Oh, I got it!
I got it!
Oh my god!
We got trolled so... We got trolled so hard, Gumi!
Oh, this is bad.
We got trolled.
Alright, back to it.
I've seen the chest.
I'm just gonna follow Gumi.
Oh no, we have to... We saw it too!
Oh my god, this is so nerve-wracking!
Literally one guy!
I got so confused!
That's so fucked up.
It's so fucked up.
Alright, we're going upstairs.
Where's the chest?
It's upstairs.
Yeah, there's a pile of books upstairs.
Hey, it's really hard to speak Spanish so they don't understand.
Where's the chest?
Oh wait, no, it's this chest.
It's this chest.
It's behind me.
And where do I take the note?
I followed Gumi!
I got confused!
Yes!
Never follow Gumi!
Use the note to find a chest.
Try 1993.
Oh, is it the number on your file?
1... 1... 93...
Wait, I'm not in?
Where do I take it?
Find the note right here.
Right there.
1993.
The code is 1993.
Click on it.
1993.
Alright, Gia, the books are at the top of the barn, okay, Gia?
Oh god.
The chest is behind the barn.
Oh, I got panicked, guys!
I panicked!
I panicked, everybody!
I couldn't read because I was panicking!
Did you get the note?
Did you get the note up there?
No, it's me.
Did you get the note?
Run, run, run!
Come on!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Find a note near the pile of books.
Oh my god.
Where's the note?
Book?
Oh, thanks.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is that it?
We're good?
Up here?
I don't know where to go.
There's gonna be...
I'm gonna come over here.
Books right here?
Do we have to fight right now?
Yeah!
Nice.
Nice, Ross!
Where's the book?
I'm so stressed out!
Holy fuck!
Oh my god.
So stressful!
Oh my god!
Use your note!
I'm clicking it with the note and it's not opening!
Oh my god!
I'm gonna practice!
Yo, you guys wanna do an Autry practice right now?
Oh my god!
Yeah, I'm gonna go shoot.
I'm gonna practice, guys.
Oh god, there's falloff.
Which one's my arrow?
For the silverfish, right?
Silverfish is one of the bottom.
Okay.
We got aim high.
I don't even know which one's mine.
Yeah, I'm just gonna go to the middle.
There's no point in winning.
Oh, it's for practice.
I see.
I wish I was better with the bow.
Okay.
What are we gonna use the sword for?
Gumi went the wrong way several times!
I couldn't trust her anymore!
I couldn't trust her!
She went the wrong way several times!
Sonic got 11 points!
Sorry, Fox got eliminated.
Yeah, you were...
You were...
You were a ghost!
One in each side.
Oh, oh.
These chickens!
Fuck!
Deal!
Going this way.
Going to the house.
I don't know, I'm scared.
Oh god, they're going inside.
I'm going to the house.
They are coming this way.
Oh god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Which way are they coming over?
I'm so scared!
No no no no no no no.
Oh no, oh no, oh no, guys, goodbye, everybody!
Goodbye, everyone!
This might be where we end up!
We die!
This might be where we die!
Nooooo!
Okay.
Oh no.
Oh fucking no.
Oh no, guys, this is it.
We actually got hit.
Oh no.
Yes.
This is it, guys.
It was so nice playing with you guys!
We're gonna get eliminated by the curse!
To the gate, to the gate.
To the gate!
Where am I gonna make it?
Are we gonna make it to the gate?
We might make it.
We might make it to the gate.
We might make it to the gate!
I knew the key!
I was there!
I was there at the key!
I was the key person!
Stay here, stay here, stay here.
Get away, get away, get away.
Run,
run, run.
Dude, they tried to get me.
They tried to get me out.
I knew it was going to start with the bomb.
I knew it.
I'm behind!
I'm behind the gate!
The gate!
Really bad.
Move,
you fuckers!
You all need to get out of my way.
I swear to God I'm going to freak out.
I can't tell how many I killed.
I can't match my freak.
Try to quit, try to quit.
Don't spam, try to quit.
Oh my God, please.
Give me one.
This...
Give me one at least.
Oh my God, how many did I get?
Free firing.
Oh no.
It's a joke.
It's a joke, eh?
If you get critical, it's one-shot, so...
Oh my God.
How do you flash like that?
Bow them.
Okay.
Jump, get critical, and kill the one.
And that's it.
There's no problem.
I can't.
That's it, but...
Oh no, I can't see.
It's actually sun.
God!
Red, there's a bunch outside the barn.
Red, there's a ton outside.
Oh my God.
Okay, good.
Oh my God, I need one more.
It's on outside.
I need one more too!
Oh God.
Okay.
This way is faster.
You can jump up from the stairs.
Two way.
And jump from here.
Oh no, no, no.
Where's the Conjure?
In the middle?
Okay.
How do we get there?
Break around the...
How do you guys get there?
Oh no.
I was actually in time.
It's either the cake or the target practice.
Oh.
Oh my God.
Oh, I collided.
Give me the meat!
I'm so stressful.
I hate this game.
Oh my God.
Guys, please.
Just eliminate me.
Guys, I'm gonna be the last 10.
There's no fucking way.
Oh.
This is too much.
My heart.
My fucking heart, man.
My fucking heart.
My heart.
My fucking heart, man.
I can't.
My hands are shaking.
And I'm so stressed out.
And I want this to be over.
Oh boy.
No, no, no.
I'm just gonna go here.
My heart can't take it.
My heart can't take it, guys.
One.
How many challenges are left, too?
I'm assuming there's two more challenges and then one more ChrisRant, probably.
How many have we done so far?
We've done four ChrisRants.
If someone could hit this double Neo, they're never getting tagged.
No, I don't think you can.
Wait.
I got it, I got it.
Wait, that's just so much better, isn't it?
Jesus Christ, I got infected as the first person.
But he didn't notice I infected him back.
So we're safe.
Oh my god, dude.
I'm like hungry.
I can't.
So smart, so smart.
We're here, we're here!
I know, but you...
Hi!
I know, but you're crazy.
Wait, is there one more...
Hang in there, Toki.
Uh-oh.
Wait, they're getting tagged, they're getting tagged.
Uh-oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh, stinky.
You're not just gonna hide here, aren't you gonna dip?
Aren't you gonna dip?
Yeah, let's hide here then.
Wee!
Okay, if they run in through stairs, we need to just escape again.
Guys, I'm a little nervous.
Yeah, I'm taking the route out the back if they get up the stairs.
I love your spot down there.
Stinky.
The best point.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, surely.
We're good, we're good.
Guys, if they come in, we're good.
Ten seconds.
Internal panic.
Oh, God.
You ready?
Jump down there to fight them.
Yay, we lived just to get eliminated.
No!
We lived to get eliminated.
It's water time.
Oh, my God, of course it's bucket, bro.
Oh, it's over there.
You think the water well has the bucket?
It says it on the top left.
Hello.
We didn't go the wrong way, so that's good.
Cow pen, where's the cow pen?
Cow pen, it's at the cow pen, at the cow pen.
Where's the cow pen?
Where the fuck is the cow pen?
It's over here, it's over here.
Cow pen.
Brown cow?
Follow the Spanish minecrafters.
The cows look a little silly today.
I don't think we know where we're going.
Here, here, here.
Oh, we're going to the pig pen or the weasel pen.
Weasel pen.
Follow the Spanish Follow the Spanish minecrafters.
Bear.
Look, there's the hen.
They know what they're doing.
Is it kick time?
It's kick time, guys.
Get the recipe ready, guys!
Get the recipe ready!
Guys, how do I get to that weed faster?
Guys, I don't know how to get to the weed!
Guys, GG's, guys.
It was...
It was a good run.
I don't know how to get to that weed.
I'm so...
I'm gonna go here.
Guys, GG.
It was a good run.
I don't know how to get to that weed faster.
It was a good run!
Goodbye.
Goodbye, everybody.
I'm too stressed out to do jumps.
Oh, guys.
Collect an egg.
Oh, I know how to get the egg!
This way?
Oh.
Guys, GG's.
I don't know the route.
Oh, no.
I forgot the egg route.
Guys!
I forgot how... Guys, where's the eggs?
Yeah, it has to be our tree next, right?
But next one's awesome.
Guys, where's the eggs?
Guys,
where's the eggs?
Where's the chicken coop?
Oh, is that the chicken coop?
Is this the chicken coop?
No?
Where's the eggs?
Farmer house?
Is it this way?
Oh, guys.
I didn't know where the eggs were.
I didn't know where the eggs were, guys.
Is this where the eggs are?
Guys!
I didn't know where the eggs are.
GG's.
Guys, do you know where the eggs?
I'm confused.
Where are the eggs?
Nobody's helping!
Guys, it was a good run.
I actually don't know where the eggs are.
Guys, do you guys know where the eggs are?
Guys?
Do you guys know where the eggs are?
Yeah.
Where's the farmer's house again?
I think I'm out though.
I'm fucking GG's.
Do you know where the farmer's eggs are?
I think it's over.
I got lost in the eggs.
I survived the second day.
My chat fucked me.
My chat made me lost.
And me too.
I'm lost too.
We're both lost.
Right click, right click, hurry.
Right click, hurry and run out.
Okay.
We got the eggs.
We both got... chat, it's you and I.
We both got lost together.
Doki.
Yeah?
Come on, hurry, hurry, hurry.
I'm hurrying, I'm hurrying, I'm hurrying.
I'm so lost.
It was a good run, Gumi.
No, come on, Doki, run!
You live on for me, Gumi.
Gumi, live on for me.
It's too late.
It's too late, Gumi.
We had a good run.
You and we, just live.
Gumi.
It's okay.
It's over, Gumi.
You have to accept the fact that it's over.
Gumi, it's over.
It's over at last.
Yes!
Alright, I'm here to curse you all now.
It's time to curse.
Oh, my God.
It's so cold.
It's time.
Yes!
Alright, it's time to be the curse.
Yes.
Oh, my God.
We're both idiots.
Shane, I was banking on following you this round.
Oh, my God.
You seem very indecisive.
We're both idiots.
Which is kind of concerning me.
Umi actually clutched it.
Well, now you're going to my spot.
What?
No, no, no, trust.
Trust, trust, trust.
They're coming, they're coming.
They went the other way at the start.
So I don't know if they went the other way.
We know he clutched it through the round with the chest.
Josh, how do we get out of this place?
Bro, you have to clutch up.
It's the only way.
Where's Sylvie?
Hi, Apple.
I think people discovered our spot.
They're coming, they're coming.
Run here, run here.
I don't know what I said.
I'm putting the chair under the table.
Sorry.
Guys, ball in the middle.
Don't move, don't move.
Try to get momentum.
Come in, come in, come in.
Umi actually took me to the finish line.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
Shout out to Umi.
Shout out to Umi for taking me all the way to the end.
So how are y'all doing?
What the...
Hola.
I'm trying to get you bullied.
Guys, we're both idiots, guys.
There were so many instructions that I got scared.
You know I panicked, guys.
You know I panicked.
We were both at fault.
That's all, that's all.
Except the fact that we both wanted to get there.
Oh no.
Okay, now this is where we leave.
I got Kadazzer theme.
How is someone already finished?
You're blocking my shots, bro.
Give me a little space here, man.
I'm done, I'm done.
I got 12th, man.
I kinda choked.
Locked in.
We should probably back the fuck up.
That's so mean.
Oh god.
Umi.
What?
That's it?
No.
Okay.
Soki, you can do it.
Bullet drop off, bullet drop off.
Aim a little higher.
Okay.
Nice, Soki.
Oh, I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it!
I got it, I got it, I got it!
One more, one more, one more!
One more, you got it!
I have to do another day of this.
Umi.
We have to do day three, Umi.
Wait, wait.
You mean it!
We have to do day three, Umi.
You're the very last person!
I hate that.
Oh my god.
I was... Umi clutched it and I was 85.
And then I tagged somebody instantly.
I know, I saw.
Oh my god.
Umi, you did it.
Me and my chat.
Now we play Valorant after this.
Okay, Umi, my heart cannot take it right now.
I'm fucking...
I just want you to know.
I went through like the five stages of grief there.
Oh my god, no.
My anxiety was peaking for you.
The entire game, I didn't feel super anxious until you had...
Oh my god.
I was so lost.
I didn't know where the eggs were.
I was begging.
Minecrafters are so cruel.
Nobody would tell me where the eggs are.
And then sometimes they lie.
Sometimes they tell you and then I'm like, I don't believe you.
I can't believe it.
You're not allowed to swear.
But they gaslight us instead.
They gaslight us.
We made it.
We did it.
Is something scary going to happen?
And then there's a possibility that we don't make it because...
Guys, I don't know where the four embers are.
There's so many houses.
The hard part was you guys were like, Stop.
Back.
There.
Forward.
That was what fucked me up.
You guys were like, back.
Forward.
And I was like, back.
Front.
Left.
Oh my god.
When I was on the main stream.
I said my truth.
I said my truth, guys.
My truth.
I didn't study.
Please.
A barn can be a house.
I don't know.
I haven't been on the farm before.
I'm a city gal.
I don't know what's what.
You don't say.
Oh my god.
40 people tomorrow.
40 people get eliminated tomorrow?
40 elims tomorrow.
I still need two more.
A house is a house.
Tubbo died for this.
Yeah.
A minecrafter died so I can live on today.
Gumi, please.
Gumi, I don't know in my heart.
What if I get a five stack?
It's a five stack.
A five stack?
Okay, if you get a five stack going.
I'm gonna go grab food though.
I haven't finished my food.
The last Vtuber lives on.
The last Vtuber died so I can be in day three.
I can't believe it.
I took an actual minecrafter spot.
Too mean.
Hi.
Where's the new easter egg?
Equivalent exchange.
I'm just happy it's over.
I'm happy.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe.
Tomorrow we go again.
Oh my god.
I barely made it like four times.
I should not be alive.
I already was going through like the five stages of grief of getting eliminated.
Like...
I have the plot armor.
I'm the main character.
The main character plot.
Guys, guys.
How about we both agreed that we both fucked up together that we both fucked up together during that, the egg part.
The egg section, we both messed up.
Okay?
As a group, we both take responsibility.
And then Gumi clutched it for us.
Gumi clutched it for us.
But we both messed up together.
Oh my god.
Okay, group picture time.
Oh gosh.
How can we celebrate anything?
He's gone.
Who's gone?
Everyone's gone.
Yeah, I took...
I was the last person.
I took a minecrafter's place.
I don't even play this game.
I just learned E is inventory today.
That's crazy.
And Tubbo lost to me.
That's amazing.
Oh my gosh.
What a horrifying thing to hear.
Yay.
Are we looking at the same area?
I don't know.
Where am I supposed to look at?
I...
I hope I'm looking at the...
I hope I'm looking at the right area.
I don't know.
Who's the cameraman?
Two minutes?
Oh.
Okay.
No.
I have to be in front for exposure.
As one of the last few non-Minecraft players in this lobby, I deserve to be in the front.
Who messed up the...
That's not fair.
You guys have to be mature about this.
I was mature enough to take responsibility.
But now you guys also have to be mature enough to also take responsibility.
Guys.
We are mature adults here.
We should both equally take the blame.
Guys.
We both equally share the blame.
But we can all agree.
Gumi clutched it for us.
Gumi saved our asses.
Who was it?
That kept on going.
Left.
Right.
Back.
Forward.
Yay.
We did it.
No.
It was me.
Guys.
Look.
I was very overwhelmed.
As the non-Minecraft player.
I am already directionally challenged.
Guys.
I was already very directionally challenged.
Oh.
You finally relaxed.
Why does...
Guys.
Why did my urge of wanting to win overpowered my rest week?
I can't believe we made it today.
It doesn't matter.
We are going to get eliminated anyway.
We are just too competitive.
Oh my god.
This is the most stressful rest week of all time.
It really is.
It's actually the most stressful rest week we've had.
Each game has... It's like...
Why am I so stressed out?
Oh my god.
Yes.
Alright.
We are going to call it here.
Apparently, Gumi wants to 5-stack Valorant.
So we might be back after I finish eating.
And...
After we finish eating and...
Give...
Wait.
What was I going to say?
Fuck.
Oh, sorry.
After I finish eating we might pop up on Gumi's stream.
And so I'm going to give her a raid.
Hey guys!
For those who are new here, I actually stream on the YouTube's.
It's less stressful over there.
It's a lot less stressful over on the YouTube's side.
So check me out there.
If you don't want...
If you don't want anxiety in each game because I don't know how to read.
Check me out on the YouTube.
And if you guys want to know whenever I go live on Twitch.
Check me out on...
Follow me on Twitter.
So you know whenever I'm live on Twitch, guys.
And...
If you want to support me through other means.
Please feel free to check out my merch.
Hey guys.
I can finally stop shaking.
I swear nothing has made me as anxious or stressed out lately but this.
Like I don't even play Minecraft.
I don't know why.
I don't even play Minecraft.
Why is this so fucking nerve wracking?
Hey guys.
As always everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get more around to get that blood flowing.
And if you suffer from it, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.
Forgot to say thank you for all the subs, bits, and files.
Sorry I've been so stressed out that I've been so forgetful.
Bonus ending.
Thank you for all the subs, bitties, and files everybody.
Anyway, bye for real.